not every Hollywood after makes millions
former Cosby star Jeffrey Owens works at
a grocery store today and some haters
are actually shaming him for it here's
the thing Nancy this story has exploded
as so many actors have come to his
defense including keshia knight pulliam
Cosby's little Rudy I am overwhelmed in
a good way but it is overwhelming
former Cosby star Jeffrey Owens feared
the absolute worst when these photos of
him working at Trader Joe's were public
over the weekend what they did was they
appeal to the Wurster natures and people
and I think they were surprised to find
that the better natures and people
totally triumphed in this case actress
Patricia Heaton blasted the initial
story asking why are you trying to
humiliate this honorable hard-working
actor Brooklyn nine-nine star Terry
Crews tweeted I swept floors after the
NFL if need be I do it again Jeffrey
played Bill Cosby's son-in-law
Elvin on The Cosby Show for more than
six years the 57 year old actor also
recently lost money from The Cosby Show
residuals after several cable channels
drop reruns in the wake of Bill Cosby
sexual assault conviction he continued
to work smaller ropes I guess the jig
I've appeared on a lot of shows the
problem is I haven't appeared a lot on a
lot of show dollar-wise income wise it
doesn't add up
Wolff that is changing thanks
geoffery who wore his Trader Joe's
nametag to our interview tells us the
Hollywood offers are pouring in
including one from Tyler Perry who
tweeted quote I'm about to start
shooting owns number one drama next week
come join us that's a very very generous
thing for him to say and we'll see what
happens with that I don't expect to be
offered things it would be lovely if as
one of the results of this some doors
open in terms of giving me the
opportunity to audition and we wondered
have producers from Dancing with the
Stars reached out yes they have but they
they actually to their credit they did
years ago before this stuff came up and
more support today from one of Jeffrey's
former Cosby co-stars keshia knight
pulliam
thank you I support him and I'm happy
that this has turned into be such a warm
feel good story they haven't seen each
other for more than a decade this
afternoon
et arranged this FaceTime reunion with
Keisha in Atlanta you causing quite a
ruckus I didn't mean to well look I'm
proud of you people need to know as a
working actor like you have to do what
you have to do for your family and there
is nothing wrong with a hard day's work
period point blank thank you I
appreciate it now tell me something
which Trader Joe's do you work at um you
know I haven't applied yet hey we are
all could be there one day I'm by the
way if Jeffrey does take the gig with
Tyler Perry on the haves and have-nots
then he could visit Keisha who lives in
Atlanta because that's where films there
you go and he would be on Oprah's
network bubbling works out for
[Music]